der ausbruch des vulkans unter dem
amerikanischen yellowstone nationalpark
würde eine apokalyptische katastrophe
auslösen und damit tatsächlich das
komplette leben auf der erde bedrohen
und es ist nicht unwahrscheinlich dass
diese katastrophe schon bald passiert
denn der schlummernde vulkan bricht etwa
alle 600.000 jahre aus und ist somit
wieder fällig geologen weltweit
beobachten die riesige magma kammer im
yellowstone-nationalpark deshalb ganz
genau
jetzt hat ein forschungsteam der nasa
erstmals einen plan vorgestellt um diese
gefahr zu entschärfen wie die idee
konkret aussieht und wie realistisch
ihre umsetzung ist jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
unvorstellbare 60 kilometer lang und 40
kilometer breit ist die magmakammer des
super vulkans unter dem ersten
nationalpark seinem aqua kammer fast
15.000 kubikkilometer magma also
kubikkilometer das ist der wahnsinn und
das im wörtlichen sinne
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit tüfteln schon lange an einen
plan super vulkane wie diesen besser
einschätzen zu können oder gar in den
griff zu bekommen und das ist fast
unmöglich aber es ist auch unabdingbar
um die menschheit zu retten
die zeit läuft davon denn der riesige
supervulkan im amerikanischen national
park könnte schon sehr bald ausbrechen
bislang war dies etwa alle 600.000
jahren der fall
und sein letzter ausbruch liegt
tatsächlich bereits 640.000 jahre
zurück und die gefahr die von diesem
supervulkan ausgeht ist tatsächlich ein
bewusst der nasa mitarbeiter brian
willcox beispielsweise hat erst vor
kurzem festgestellt das zitat die
forschung zu super so kann weitaus
wichtiger ist um die menschheit vor
gefahren zu schützen als die
entwicklung von systemen die kometen und
asteroiden von der erde fernzuhalten und
setzt dagegen die astrophysiker ja von
einer großen gefahr aus fest steht auf
jeden fall ein ausbruch würde eine
katastrophe für das komplette leben auf
der erde bedeuten die sonne würde von
den aschewolken so sehr verdunkelt
werden dass die ernten in vielen
regionen der welt ausfallen würden 74
tage lang würden
die weltweiten nahrungsvorräte wohl
überleben lassen danach würde wohl ein
großteil der menschen verhungern
ein katastrophales szenario das die nasa
unbedingt verhindern will ein
forschungsteam der weltraumbehörde hat
jetzt einen konkreten plan ausgearbeitet
um den superpokal zu entschärfen bzw
einen ausbruch sogar zu verhindern die
idee den yellowstone so kann
kontinuierlich abkühlen
schon länger gibt es die idee
frischwasser aus den bergen zu punkten
und dieses in den vulkan zu leiten
wirklich umsetzbar ist diese idee aber
nicht und so haben die wissenschaftler
wissenschaftlerinnen diesen vorschlag
weiter ausgearbeitet die lösung könnte
eventuell daraus bestehen ein geothermie
kraftwerk in der nähe des vulkans zu
installieren konkret müsste der vulkan
angebohrt werden
das kraftwerk würde ihm langsam aber
stetig wärme entziehen und die
magmakammer langfristig abkühlen diese
idee ist fast so grandios so wahr zu
sein denn so würde die gefahr des super
bekannt zum einen eingedämmt werden
gleichzeitig würde das geothermische
kraftwerk aber auch strom produzieren
die nasa schätzt die kosten des
projekts auf 3 1 milliarden dollar
zehn kilometer müsste beispielsweise
nach unten gebohrt werden um an 350 grad
heißes wasser zu gelangen so ließe
sich dann strom für etwa 10 cent pro
kilowattstunde herstellen falls das
projekt erfolgreich wäre könnte die
region um den vulkan wohl mehrere
hundert jahre mit strom versorgt werden
für mehrere
100 jahre wie hummer ist das denn denn
aus dem vulkan strömen derzeit hitze
mit einer energieleistung von sechs
gigawatt eigentlich viel zu schade um
das nicht zu nutzen doch die ganze idee
steckt voller risiken denn solch eine
bohrung könnte tatsächlich die
katastrophe auslösen die es eigentlich
zu verhindern gilt die magmakammer
könnte instabil werden wenn unternehmen
in die tieferen und heißeren schichten
bohren die folge
der ausbruch des supervulkan schon hier
in europa haben die bohrung für
geothermie kraftwerk er zur erdbeben
gefühlt doch es besteht tatsächlich
dringender handlungsbedarf denn der
yellowstone vulkan ist nicht der einzige
gefährliche super programm
bislang sind weltweit weitere 20 super
vulkane bekannt die durchschnittlich
etwa alle 100.000 jahre ausbrechen die
gefahr ist also wirklich konkret dass
ein solcher supervulkan in absehbarer
zeit ausbricht wenn ihr kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
supervulkan wird ausbrechen ja da gibt
es noch mal mehr infos zur gefahr durch
super wo kann also nicht verpassen und
drauf liegen aber achtung das ist nichts
für ängstliche und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran